to some trending news this afternoon  during a time when the country is  examining racial stereotypes  and diverse representation in  entertainment more than ever new tv  characters are emerging  and that includes charles little bull on  nickelodeon's the casa grandes  he is one of the first characters from  the lakota tribe  to be featured in a national animated tv  show  crystal echo hawk is the founder of  illuminative which works to promote  positive representation of native people  she says previous portrayals of  indigenous  people have been racist or negative so  seeing characters like charles  is a breath of fresh air the ability  you know to see charles is going to  really give you know young viewers the  opportunity to see a native american  in a way that i think that they're going  to be able to look up to him as a role  model  and how cool is this charles voice  character is a native american voice  actor named robbie draymond  and he is a grad of unlv fantastic